c'est l'une des images fortes de cette
journée les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 27 pays membres de
l'union européenne réunis à versailles
indépendance énergétique adhésion de
l'ukraine défense européenne les enjeux
sont nombreux et historique norbert
évangéliste à ce sommet était prévu de
longue date mais la crise ukrainienne en
a chamboulé l'ordre du jour il faut
désormais s'attaquer à l'urgence trois
gros dossiers sont sur la table des 27
qui plancheront dès cet après-midi sur
les questions de la défense et de
l'énergie
la guerre déclenchée par vladimir
poutine a mis un coup d'accélérateur à
l'objectif d'atteindre une souveraineté
militaire européenne l'allemagne a fait
un pas dans ce sens en augmentant le
budget de sa déférence la finlande et la
suède sont prêts à suivre quand d'autres
les pays baltes par exemple protéger
essentiellement par l'otan n'ont
simplement pas les moyens il ya des pays
qui étaient peut-être très dépendants
des américains et qui vont se dire
peut-être que c'est bien d'avoir un
partenariat avec les américains mais
peut-être il faudrait qu'on a un
partenariat entre européens pour avoir
nos propres capacités avec en des
coopérations qui nous permettent d'avoir
des équipements européens intéropérables
avec le temps sans doute mais qui nous
permettront de pouvoir les utiliser sans
demander l'autorisation washington si on
a besoin de le faire le dossier de
l'énergie est un air de la guerre contre
le chef du kremlin
l'europe sanctionne poutine d'une main
mais donne à la russie de l'autre par
ses achats d'énergie dont elle ne peut
se priver à court terme certains états
membres comme l'allemagne sont très
dépendants du gaz russe
contrairement à la france qui a fait le
choix du nucléaire aussi parvenir à
s'entendre sur une stratégie commune est
un point sur lequel les vingt-sept
devront surmonter leurs divisions la
stratégie que nous devons bâtir et c'est
la discussion que nous allons avoir ce
soir c'est pourquoi ce sommet est très
important
c'est de savoir à quel rythme nous
pouvons
diminuer réduire puis supprimer cette
vulnérabilité
quelles sont les voies et moyens pour
trouver d'autres fournisseurs à court
terme et comment nous réorganiser se
libérer de la dépendance militaire à
l'otan d'un côté et de l'énergie russe
de l'autre un coup c'est le troisième
dossier sur lequel les pays de l'union
devront travailler il y à un peu moins
de deux ans face à la crise du coc vide
les 27 s'étaient entendus sur un plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros sans
doute leur faudra-t-il cette fois encore
mettre la main à la poche ou est ce
qu'on ne fait rien ou est ce qu'on se
dit que il va falloir quand même faire
en sorte que la récession ne soit pas
trop forte et donc là c'est peut-être en
effet imaginer un nouveau plan alors est
ce que c'est un plan de relance est ce
que c'est un nouveau plan
d'investissement
une prochaine réunion est prévue dans
une quinzaine de jours elle devrait
permettre d'évaluer les avancées des 27
sur chacun de ces dossiers leur routine
c'est le thème de notre débat et ça
commence à discuter en plateau entre mes
invités qui sont évidemment passionné et
rina mitri chine bon soir bienvenue vous
êtes historienne traductrice maître de
conférences à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
spécialiste de l'ukraine sylvain kahn
bonsoir docteur en géographie et
professeur agrégé à sciences po
spécialiste des questions européennes
je cite le titre de votre livre histoire
de la construction de l'europe depuis
1945 aux presses universitaires de
france olivier dorgan bonsoir avocat au
cabinet ashurst spécialiste des
sanctions économiques avec nous
également en duplex vincent couronne qui
est chercheur en droit européen à
l'université de paris saclay directeur
des surligneurs vont soir vincent
partenaires de public sénat pour faire
le pardon du de l'anglicisme le la
vérification voilà pour ne pas dire fact
checking juridique des campagnes et des
propositions des candidats dans cette
présidentielle laetitia crise politique
est évidemment à mes côtés il y a
au-delà du symbole le symbole
d'aujourd'hui irina dmitri chine c'est
évidemment cette photo de famille les
vingt-sept réunis à versailles le sommet
qui a commencé qui se déroule
aujourd'hui et demain qu'est ce que vous
en attendez vous au delà de cette image
ils prennent attend les décisions qui
seront prises
concernant la candidature de l'ukraine
la moldavie la géorgie il n'y a pas non
plus d'attentes excessive j'ai regardé
les la presse ça valait les infos
ukrainienne et je n'ai pas vu des
annonces de cette rencontre donc avec
l'ukraine est quand même dans
l'actualité sur le terrain et mais il
est évident que la décision est le
symbole de cette décision serra sera
étudiée c'est intéressant ce que nous
dit parce que il ya le symbole de
effectivement est ce qu on acte le début
du processus on va y revenir tout à
l'heure de de l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne mais on va beaucoup
parler dans ce débat notamment de la
question énergétique d'un embargo ou pas
sur le gaz et le pétrole russe ça c'est
pas évoqué comme un moyen de pression
contre poutine peut-être comme un moyen
de l'arrêter voyez ce que je veux dire
parce que pour nous c'est vraiment
l'enjeu de ce sommet et en ukraine on
n'en parle pas non on comprend on
reproche en fait à l'europe sans naïveté
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut
peut-être poser la question comment l
europe s'est retrouvée prise au piège a
laissé un monopoliste comme ça à à
pouvoir manipuler et exercé des
chantages parce que l'ukraine a été
objet de ce chantage il ya quelques
années donc on a on est on est conscient
du poids que cela représente mais bien
évidemment ce qui préoccupe l'ukraine
aujourd'hui c'est la situation sur le
terrain les négociations qui n'ont rien
donné apparemment et rencontre entre les
deux ministres des affaires étrangères
évidemment sylvain kahn depuis quinze
jours l'europe a démontré une capacité à
agir vite collectivement est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre ce sommet démarre à
peine
macron accueillait les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement en milieu fin d'après
midi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
front uni ou alors craindre les premiers
tiraillements les premières fracture il
semble que
maintenir un front uni va être un
objectif politique tout à fait
primordiale et probablement on va bien
voir probablement ce sera un objectif
partagé par les vingt-sept plus ursula
von der leyen plus charles michel donc
il me semble que la question c'est pour
parvenir à préserver ce front uni
jusqu'à quel point va-t-il falloir
trouver un compromis qui fasse que tout
le monde monte à bord c'est plutôt ça
qui va se passer donc ça veut dire que
mes la deuxième chose je crois c'est que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en tous les cas l'opinion
publique européenne la société
européenne est très très mobilisé on va
dire aux côtés des ukrainiens alors aux
côtés comme on peut c'est à dire on fait
des dons on accueille des gens
et et je pense que par rapport à ça
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement on
est en démocratie
alors des fois on reproche beaucoup
démocratie d'être versatile mais là en
tous les cas dans les régimes
démocratiques en général les dirigeants
suivent un peu leurs opinions publiques
et je vois mal comment dans le contexte
actuel avec ses demandes sociales de
soutien à l'ukraine les vingt-sept ne
n'enverrait pas des signes forts à leur
opinion publique qu'ils soutiennent
l'ukraine parce que c'est ce que leurs
électeurs veulent oui on peut même
considérer que s'est renforcée par l'une
des informations d'une des images de
cette journée le bombardement de cet
hôpital pédiatrique et maternité à
marioupol comme vous le dites les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement qui sont en ce
moment à versailles ils sont ils sont
perméables à la pression de leur opinion
publique est un événement comme celui là
il va forcément ont peut-être pas on
peut se dire une fin finalement c'est
d'abord la raison et et les enjeux d'un
sommet européen qui vont prendre le pas
ou est ce qu'ils vont céder à cette
émotion à cette pression de l'émotion
quand on vous l'imaginez ça
j'imagine que ça ne donnera pas des
résultats spectaculaires
c'est un résultat spectaculaire ça
serait quoi ça serait soit effectivement
décrété un embargo sur les exportations
les importations de gaz ou de pétrole
russe et pour les raisons qu'on était
dit dans le journal dans le reportage ça
paraît très improbable de décider
aujourd'hui que le 30 mars on arrête
complètement alors j'irai peut-être un
horizon comme viennent de le faire les
britanniques l'autre manière
spectaculaire de faire ça serait de
décréter que oui on envoie des avions de
chasse à l'ukraine
pour l'instant beaucoup de chefs d'état
et gouvernement dise attention il
faudrait pas qu'on donne à l'armée russe
le prétexte
de dire que l'ue est en guerre bien qu
belligérantes bon la troisième raison ce
serait carrément d'envoyer d'une manière
ou d'une autre ça peut être des
commandes ondes et ça peut être des
troupes spéciales enfin d'envoyer un
soutien
auprès de l'armée ukrainienne pour
l'instant ce n'est pas évoqué mais je là
je réponds à votre question de manière
spéculative qu'est ce que ça serait un
soutien
on peut imaginer un procès un procès
exceptionnel
où soudainement l'ukraine est adoptée
par par l'ordre ça serait spectacle mois
par rapport à ça je pense que ce qui
pourrait arriver alors n'oublions pas
qu'il ya le sommet de versailles et puis
dans 15 jours il ya à nouveau conseil
européen des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui était prévu parce que
y'en a toujours 4 1 jour 1 au mois de
mars quoi indépendamment de ceux qui
sont organisées par le pays qu'à la
présidence effectivement je suis assez
d'accord avec vous pour considérer qu'il
est probable que si les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement veulent donner à leur
opinion publique et à l'opinion publique
aux ukrainiennes faire un vrai signe à
moindre coût ça serait de dire ok on
accorde le statut de pays candidat alors
je me tourne vers vincent couronnes là
dessus je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur en droit européen
l'université de paris saclay normalement
la procédure elle et elle est lourde
elle est longue et les landes c'est ça
oui une procédure pour adhérer à l'union
européenne s'est effectivement lourd
même si théoriquement il n'y a qu'une
seule exigence à respecter pour rentrer
dans l'union européenne qui est exigé
par les traiter c'est respecter les
valeurs de l'état de droit et c'est être
l'état européen évidemment le maroc
avait essayé d'être candidat à une
époque on l'a rapidement dit que je
n'étais pas un état européen mais ça
prend du temps malgré tout parce que les
états membres ont ajouté des critères
économiques démocratiques sociaux de
stabilité etc et que la croatie par
exemple elle a mis dix ans pour adhérer
à l'union européenne
alors on pourrait très bien envisager
d'accélérer le processus période pour
l'ukraine juridiquement c'est tout à
fait faisable mais ça poserait quand
même des problèmes assez assez important
alors il ya des problèmes économiques le
le salaire moyen et craignent un s'est
il est dix fois inférieur au salaire
moyen des européens donc c'est quand
même pas non plus forcément facile à
intégrer et puis ça pose des problèmes
aussi stratégique et militaire parce que
quand on adhère à l'union européenne
déjà en plus parle juste partie d'un
marché ont fait partie d'une communauté
qui on le voit de plus en plus solidaire
et puis aussi surtout en fait partie
d'une communauté qui promet de défendre
ses membres en cas d'attaqué militaire
c'est ce qui est prévu par le traité sur
l'union européenne et donc intégré à
l'etac est déjà en guerre c'est faire
des 27 états membres de l'union
européenne et à qui se retrouvent en
guerre de fait face à la russie
je vous ai pas encore donné la parole
olivier doran poids pour vous le l'enjeu
principal de ce sommet européen c'est
d'abord la question de l'indépendance ou
de la dépendance énergétique oui surtout
que nos alliés américains et
britanniques nous ont grillé la
politesse
en instaurant un embargo sur les
produits pétroliers russes pour les
états unis de gazon de gaz également et
2 et 2 et charbon est en tout cas une
annonce et planifiée de la sortie du
royaume-uni des imports de ces mêmes
matières premières peut-être que pour
rebondir sur ce qui était dit je pense
que la probabilité d'un embargo total et
immédiat sur les imports de gaz et
pétrole paraît assez un peu assez
improbable par contre ce qui pourrait se
dessiner me semble-t-il c'est une déjà
un signe fort pourrait être d'interdire
aux sociétés européennes qui sont encore
actives sur le territoire russe de
continuer à prêter leur concours sur des
projets existants ça pourrait être une
forme d'entre eux deux qui ne nous
couperait pas complètement de notre
dépendance encore très forte pour
certains pays notamment l'allemagne et
la slovaquie au gaz et au pétrole russe
mais en même temps ça enverrait un
message assez fort et ça permettrait
surtout parce qu'on vous parliez d'unité
européenne au delà d'une idée européenne
ya une unité occidentale me semble-t-il
qui est tout aussi primordial et c'est
sur cette non unités occidentale que la
lumière poutine mise depuis le début de
ces guerres il attend de voir se
fissurer ce front et ce front a commencé
un peu à se fissurer lundi soir quand
mardi soir pendant quand joe biden a
annoncé il ya un peu pris de surprise
d'ailleurs
l'annoncé à l'embargo sur le pétrole
alors c'était évidemment beaucoup plus
facile pour les états unis je vais
donner quelques chiffres sur sept ce
chapitre dans notre débat les
importations de gaz en france elles
viennent d'abord de norvège à 36% de
russie à 17% ensuite c'est l'algérie et
les pays bas à
8% et on va on va dérouler
ces chiffres avec ensuite la part des
importations de gaz en provenance de
russie alors là le comparatif vous
l'avez fait mais qui est intéressant et
qui est frappant c'est le l'allemagne la
france 66 % pour l'allemagne 17 % pour
la france et il faut aussi parler du
pétrole la part des importations de
pétrole cette fois ci en provenance de
russie là aussi la différence est
importante entre l'allemagne et la
france 30 % l'allemagne 13% en france
irina dmitri chine vous vous êtes
ukrainienne si le coeur parle vous
demandez j'imagine un embargo européen
si la raison l'emporté ce que vous
comprenez les hésitations notamment de
l'allemagne suit aussi citoyenne
européenne je comprends parfaitement
les enjeux dans dans ta les deux parties
ce que je pense qu'il est important de
dire que ceux ci on ne soutient pas
l'ukraine aujourd'hui ça coûtera plus
cher à l'europe après c'est à dire qu'il
faut être conscient que ces chiffres ses
pertes et ses calculs actuels il faut
les voir qu'est-ce qui se passera si
l'ukraine tombe donc est ce que on
n'aura pas à payer un prix encore plus
fort et je pense qu'on ne gagne jamais à
renier nos valeurs et pourquoi parce que
l'appétit de poutine ne s'arrêtera pas à
une réponse je pense qu'il est tout à
fait capable d'ailleurs il a il a dit la
demande est déjà le retrait de l'otan et
il parle tantôt du glacis soviétique
tantôt de l'empiré russe donc donc je
pense que si les voisins occidentaux de
l'ukraine sont aussi mobilisés parce
qu'ils ont encore le souvenir de ce qui
était la présence soviétique ou russes
qui la redoutent surtout aujourd'hui
sylvain kahn un embargo total décidé là
à versailles je pense que personne
autour de cette table ne peut ne peux y
croire parce que la dépendance est trop
forte vous l'avez dit pour pour
l'allemagne et les autres pays que vous
avez cités slovaquie la slovaquie pardon
donc on peut aller vers quoi vous
l'avais un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
mais ça peut être un calendrier pour se
passer de je ne sais pas 40 50 60 % du
gaz et du pétrole russes à terme oui ça
peut être ça d'autant plus que ce type
de comment est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
ça de raisonnement ou de mise en place
d'une nouvelle politique publique
ressemble beaucoup aux fins et très
européen c'est à dire de se fixer un
objectif un horizon un calendrier alors
en général on fait ça pour
l'entrée dans la monnaie unique on étale
sa sur dix ans on fait ça pour les
élargissements ça a été rappelé en
est-elle ça sur plusieurs années bon en
tout les cas il me semble que la
commission européenne qui est quand même
l'administration en charge de faire
tourner les politiques publiques
européennes elle sait très bien faire ça
et puis même si ça peut paraître un peu
comment dire un peu bizarre le
rapprochement que je vais faire il se
trouve que avant le début de l'invasion
de l'ukraine par la russie les européens
ont adopté un green deal avec un
objectif de transition énergétique et de
sortie de l'économie carbonées
précisément d'ici à 2050 étalé sur
plusieurs années par payet et c'est donc
de ce point de vue là on pourrait
imaginer que oui effectivement les
européens vont chercher
à énoncer des objectifs peut-être un
calendrier voilà en même temps moi ce
qui
disons il me semble qu'il faut aussi
mais peut-être que je me trompe
complètement qu'on envisage le fait qu'
il ya encore pas longtemps on va le dire
comme ça on envisage l inverse dire on
se demandait s'il n'y avait pas le
risque en s'opposant entre guillemets à
la russie que la russie puisse couper le
robinet alors aujourd'hui est ce que
cette crainte a totalement disparu ou
pas je ne sais pas il a besoin de ces
délices et revient sur l'argent donc il
ya quand même ça marche dans les deux
sens ici qu'ils achètent on est d'accord
on est d'accord mais d'ailleurs je
passais pas une colle mais ça ça
rapporte combien à la russie oui les
noms des exportations de gaz et de
pétrole aux évidemment tiens je vais je
vous laisse
la réponse on va d'abord écouté pardon
je fais un peu les choses à l'envers
mais on va d'abord écouté là dessus
l'eurodéputé bernard guetta parce que
c'est intéressant ce qu'ils disent est
est ce matin sur lci vous donne la
parole juste après nous disons toujours
et c'est vrai nous sommes dépendants du
gaz et du pétrole russes oui bien sûr
c'est vrai mais la russie est totalement
dépendante du prix que nous lui payons
pour acquérir son gaz c'est à dire que
si nous n'achetons plus le gaz nous
asséchant non pas les radiateurs de la
russie mais nous à sécheron les coffres
forts de monsieur poutine coffre fort
qui lui sert à bombarder notamment la
maternité de marioupol mais tout le pays
en vérité et c'est vrai que ce voile à
cet enjeu moral il est il est majeur et
alors si on revient vers l'enjeu
financier c'est quoi effectivement pour
la russie ce qui est assez
contre-intuitif c'est qu'on parle
beaucoup du gaz russe mais le pétrole
est beaucoup plus générateurs de
recettes importantes pour la russie que
le gaz le gaz représente environ 50
milliards de dollars dans terme d'export
annuellement pour la russie le pétrole
globalement 180 avec une ventilation de
110 sur du brut et 60 se disent sûres du
raffiné et donc ça peut être aussi
intéressant en terme de stratégie on
parle de ce temps bargot sur l'énergie
parce qu'on s'inscrit dans cette idée
américaine on pourrait très bien aussi
envisagée on est moins dépendant du
pétrole russe est par ailleurs le
pétrole ça chemine beaucoup plus
facilement le problème du gaz c'est
qu'il est liquéfié c'est toute la
problématique des infrastructures de
nord stream un de nord stream 2 de
l'ancien gazoduc qui passait par
l'ukraine le pétrole qui soit brut ou
raffiné se transporte très facilement
donc c'est beaucoup plus simple en
termes de réserves stratégiques
également de se passer du pétrole russe
qui par ailleurs représente des revenus
beaucoup plus important pour la russie
que de se passer pour nous du du gaz
dont on est par ailleurs beaucoup plus
dépendants et dans la logistique est
beaucoup plus complexe à mettre en
oeuvre et là pour le coup le symbole
serait le symbole et le coût pour la
russie serait très fort c'est ce que je
comprends oui c'est une réalité je sais
qu'on en a pas beaucoup parlé en france
mais la loi que les états unis ont
adopté mardi soir est une loi qui vient
de toute manière mettre des bâtons très
fort dans les roues des quelques grands
groupes européens qui continuent d'agir
en russie le pétrole se mélangent le
pétrole est très difficilement traçable
et donc pour des groupes comme total
l'énergie qui ont une exposition forte
aux états unis garantir que le pétrole
qu'ils vendent ne contient pas du
pétrole russe ça va être un vrai casse
tête et donc ils vont devoir assez
rapidement à me semble-t-il choisir
entre le marché russe qui est certes
important pour eux et le marché
américain je pense que là pour le coup
là mais c'est relativement rapidement
dit pour les groupes énergétiques
français
vincent couronne dans le fonctionnement
d'un sommet comme celui qui se déroule
en ce moment à versailles on est
forcément dans une décision à
l'unanimité comment ça marche
en fait le conseil européen ce sont les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
états membres dans
[Musique]
son activité principale
quand ils se réunissent conseil européen
il n'est là que pour discuter et donner
les grandes orientations politiques de
l'union et il n'a pas de pouvoirs
législatifs
ça c'est important de comprendre se dire
qu'il ne prend pas de décision le
conseil européen à part sur quelques
éléments constitutionnel sur la
nomination du président et c'est la
commission mais de manière générale il
prend pas de décisions il rend des
conclusions et ses conclusions au fait
il adopte à l'unanimité
il adopte à l'unanimité des 27 états
membres ce qui peut parfois est bien
amenée à des prolongations du conseil
européen l'élève plusieurs plusieurs
jours plusieurs nuits on se souvient de
ce conseil européen s'est terminée le 21
juillet
2020 pour accoucher en fait du plan de
relance de 750 milliards il devait durer
un jour et demi il a duré quasiment cinq
jours parce qu'il refusait de se quitter
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement de
gouvernement tant qu'il n'avait pas
atteint l'unanimité ils ont réussi à
l'atteindre d'où la difficulté c'est ce
que disait un petit peu sylvain sylvain
sylvain kahn parlant tout à l'heure
c'est que ils veulent préserver cette
unité des européens face à la russie il
va falloir effectivement arrivé à pas
trop avoir d'ambition pour pouvoir
maintenir cette unité
l'europe avance au gré des crises et
l'europe doit changer voilà ce que le
président français
disette hier on écoute emmanuel bach
l'europe doit changer elle a changé sous
le coup de la pandémie elle va changer
encore plus vite et plus fort sur le
coût de la guerre
parce que la guerre en ukraine est un
bouleversement profond de nos équilibres
des croyances qui avait gagné notre
continent et donc elle doit nous
conduire à être lucide ambitieux et
prendre les décisions qui sont à la
hauteur alors évidemment c'était
la dernière réaction du président
français depuis versailles avait deux
réactions qui était qui était en balance
et c'était mieux d'avoir la toute
dernière évidemment laetitia alors on va
faire une petite parenthèse de d'imagés
de politique on était sûr notre premier
débat sur les enjeux de la
présidentielle évidemment il ya une
opportunité d'image qui est gigantesque
pour emmanuel macron là pendant ces deux
jours à écouter pour résumer le bénéfice
est totale à l'instant t il est atteint
pourquoi parce que il ya le décorum de
versailles bien sûr mais il ya toute la
puissance symbolique et la charge
historique on fait souvent des
raccourcis thomas vous savez et puis bon
bah c'est comme ça parce qu'on n'a pas
tous le nez sur la politique donc
finalement emmanuel macron il va
apparaître comment il va apparaître
comme le chef de l'europe je fais des
raccourcis mais ça peut vraiment se
faire dans la tête des français le chef
de l'europe et surtout le rempart celui
qui va maintenir la paix en europe et
c'est celui qui s'oppose à vladimir
poutine donc bien sûr que cette image là
elle est inatteignable pour tous ses
autres adversaires dans cette course
présidentielle le premier tour c'est
dans un mois et oui bien sûr il ya eu
des humiliations des déceptions dans son
rapport diplomatique avec le chef du
kremlin mais tout de même emmanuel
macron in fine et conserve cette image
encore une fois de chefs de guerre non
pas seulement au plan français mais
vraiment sur le plan européen combien de
temps dure ce bénéfice images qui encore
une fois un instant t et total ça je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas ce n'est que
du positif est que du capital accumulé
pour le chef de l'état emmanuel macron
et olaf scholz ailleurs le chancelier
allemand ont téléphoné ensemble à
vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui
c'est là aussi ça peut sembler un peu
contrainte utile il faut continuer
sylvain kahn de parler au président
russe alors qu'à côté de ça on discute
d'un embargo on discute des moyens de
l'arrêter
je voudrais pas me permettre de dire il
faut il faut pas et
j'ai entendu un de vos confrères
sur une sur une chaîne d'info utiliser
une image que j'ai trouvé très
intéressante je la reprends ici à mon
compte on a un peu l'impression
qu'emmanuel macron et dans l'équipe
européenne l'équivalent de
du super gendarme qui dans l'équipe du
gign quand on a un forcené qui menacent
de tout faire sauter et celui qui essaye
de faire en sorte qu'ils n'aillent pas
jusqu'au bout de sa conduite suicidaire
et destructrice bon
c'est sans doute nécessaire ou utile de
maintenir ouvert des canaux
diplomatiques de ce type
en même temps chaque jour qui passe et
chaque coup de fil qui passe je dis bien
en même temps renforce aussi la
compréhension ou le constat que ces
coups de fil à court terme ne change
rien et on a tous en mémoire
la rencontre qui avait duré cinq heures
et demie avec la conférence de presse je
crois que c'était le 7 février il était
deux heures du matin à moscou
kazim 11h au 23 heures ou minuit à paris
bon donc alors on peut dire aussi de la
part d'une macro et de la part de la
fiole c'est de la part de viktor orban
quoi qu'on pense de viktor orban bref on
peut dire oui quand même c'est assez osé
d'avoir des juges je sais pas de quoi
ils parlent pendant deux heures parce
que pendant ce temps-là poutine étant le
chef de guerre c'est poutine emmanuel
macron où schmoll sous charles michel il
sont ils sont ils sont chefs d'une
europe qui craint d'être agresséé d'être
entraînés dans la guerre mais pour
l'instant ils sont ils font de la
diplomatie et ceux qui sont en guerre et
qui subissent cette tragédie et ce
scandale ce sont les ukrainiens il
faudrait voir par le passé est ce que on
avait encore des liens diplomatiques par
exemple avec hitler est ce que les liens
diplomatiques ont été rompues parce que
c'est peut-être ça aussi vous avez
raison quand je trouve que là cette
analogie cette métaphore a été parfaite
parce qu'on peut se dire que tant qu'il
y à ce lien diplomatique aussi
artificielle soit il bon en tout cas
inefficace au moins ça permet de ne pas
basculer dans un déroulement historique
qui nous échapperait je pense que c'est
le calcul occidentale a en tout cas il
me semble j'ai l'impression est là
encore une fois je suis très très
prudent parce que ça se passe sous nos
yeux et on n'a pas toutes les cartes en
main pour l'analyser mai
les pouvoirs publics français et sans
doute européens voire otaniens ont
envoyé des signaux explicite aux
opinions publiques que les états majors
se parle je crois que c'est le journal
le monde qui a publié le week-end
dernier un entretien avec le chef d'état
major français dans lequel celui-ci ses
clients perdant c'est quelqu'un qui
s'exprime très peu celui ci donnait
lever un peu le voile sur les entretiens
téléphoniques il avait avec son
homologue russe voilà donc bon c'est
sans doute nécessaire besoin de toute
façon c'est bien historiquement vous
avez raison de rappeler l'histoire on
sait bien que c'est pas parce que même
quand on fait la guerre
on peut tenter de définir un cadre un
avec des limites des lignes rouges des
choses mais quelles que soient les
horreurs de la guerre en transférant son
si on l'avait la mario paul à savoir
demande une maternité enfin bon on est
d'accord comme l'armée russe a fait en
russie bien sur un an comme l a fait en
syrie comme voilà à faire enfin bon ça
et ça peut toujours être pire voilà 6 et
c'est ça qui est très difficile quand on
est citoyen ou quand on n'est pas
impliqué c'est que ça peut toujours être
pire mais irina dmitri chine sais pas si
vous avez vu il avait l'ambassadeur de
russie qui était sur le plateau d'yves
calvi
hier soir chez nos confrères de bfm à un
moment de langue de bois j'hallucine et
en voyant seul mais à quoi ça sert de
parler avec les russes ils sont dans le
mensonge permanent voyez ce que je veux
dire en termes diplomatiques fait parce
que c'était une erreur de l'invité ce
nom c'est justement pour ça que l'europe
a fermé à château-d'oex explique ce
n'est pas pour que les représentants
russes maintenant des verts selon leurs
propos sur d'autres sur d'autres
viennent au delà de ça sert dans un
dialogue de deux chefs d'état chefs
d'état c'est à dire que je j'ai alors
évidemment vous avez pas la réponse mais
on essaye de ceux de s'imaginer avec un
écouteur est ce que est ce que la nuit
en poutine est exactement dans le même
déni de réalité face à ses oeuvres ses
homologues quand il discute c'est déjà
un gala merkel qui est là qu elle a dit
il ya quelques années et je pense que
emmanuel macron là là aussi au plus ou
moins laissé entendre qu'il a découvert
un putin différent de ce qu'ils
connaissaient avant ce qui était très
intéressant c'est qu'il y avait des
propos de l'ambassadeur hier mais il y
avait aussi les propos du ministre aux
affaires étrangères russe aujourd'hui il
ya dix ans bah si on l'a bombardé parce
qu'il y avait des des combattants des
nazis etc y avait peut-être pas de
femmes donc déjà il change de deux
versions tout communes nous ont raconté
que le ring de malaz airlines a été
abattu par les ukrainiens donc en fait
on vend de servir à chaque fois un une
autre version mais aujourd'hui dieu
merci on est dans un monde où tout est
assez rapidement identifié on établira
les responsabilités assez assez
clairement et de manière assez nette je
pense que l'interview d'hier s'il ya eu
une utilité c'est de servir de document
pour le futur programme achevé d'accord
avec vous sinon parce que le support
nord où elle a lieu cette interview est
complètement différent de spoutnik et rt
il faut voir où elle a lieu cette
interview face à qui quel est le
journaliste qui l'amène comment elle et
contextualisés comment elle est décrypté
je pense que pour les opinions publiques
françaises qui sont relativement éclairé
en tout cas si on a envie on à une
information libre et étoffé ça peut
permettre de comprendre la pro grande
que vive le peuple que vivre c'est comme
ça que je les reçois c'est à dire avec
un caddie à yves calvi qui faisait son
travail et qui étaient évidemment pas de
jeu lorsque les français ne sont pas
dupes non plus parce qu'on les a aussi
on a habilité aussi leur wheeler phase
écrit ces réseaux complotistes parallèle
est née sous-estimé par l'effet corrosif
de ses propos il ya quand même beaucoup
de gens qui adhèrent à ces propos bon je
suis d'accord qu'il faut garder la laub
la proportion et je vous rejoins sur le
fait que les questions étaient posées là
massador a été poussé dans ses
retranchements mais c'était quand même
un interview hallucinante je serai sur
les enjeux de ce sommet avec cette
question qui peut sembler provocatrice
l'europe pourrait-elle déclaré la guerre
à la russie pour entrer en guerre face à
la russie vous voulez évoquer cette
question dans une tribune que vous avez
faim dans un article qui est paru dans
la tribune pardon sylvain caron ça reste
hautement improbable mais vous l'évoquez
cette question oui
tout à fait d'accord avec vous ça reste
hautement improbable mais à partir d'un
certain nombre de signaux et de signaux
faibles dont nous disposons depuis dix
jours ce n'est plus totalement
impossible et encore une fois alors je
sais que ce que je dis là c'est vraiment
un hypothèse que je verse aux débats de
façon on va dire très très prudente et
très conditionnel mais moi ce qui me
frappe encore une fois beaucoup c'est la
mobilisation
extrêmement rapide des opinions
publiques est une espèce de
cristallisation de ce qu'on peut appeler
pour aller rapidement à une sorte de
patriotisme européen avec un effet
miroir où les européens s'identifient
aux ukrainiens soit parce qu'ils ont
peur ou soit parce qu'on a peur parce
que effectivement on a encore une fois
près de 2300 km de frontière commune
avec la russie près de la menace
nucléaire oui près de 1500 km de
frontière avec l'ukraine ont
effectivement
cette guerre est
vraiment à la frontière de l'europe et
on peut se demander parce qu'un certain
nombre de pays qui aujourd'hui sont dans
l'union européenne au nom des
expériences historiques très réel très
concrètes qui ont duré des décennies
jusqu'où peut aller la russie et
l'avancée de l'armée russe voilà bon
donc la peur d'une part mais aussi le
dégoût le rejet de ce que les russes aux
ukrainiens et en même temps
l'admiration de la bravoure du peuple
ukrainien le fait que le président
zélande ce qui est devenu en quelques
jours sans doute un des personnages les
plus populaires de l'opinion publique
européenne
tout cela fait que encore une fois par
glissement progressif sans plan un
événement en amenant un autre il se
pourrait qu'à on se retrouve à prendre
ici ou là initiatives ponctuelles un
pont aérien
une colonne de véhicules blindés légers
pour exfiltrer des populations là qui
pourrait faire qu'à un moment donné on
se rendrait compte qu'on est dedans dans
une opération militaire pas
déclaré la guerre aux non-voyants
l'armée mais qui ferait qu' on serait
même de façon très ponctuelle
militairement engagés aux côtés des
ukrainiens parce qu'encore une fois il y
aurait une espèce de demande sociale le
lien patriotisme européen voilà c'est
une hypothèse j'ai pas du tout que ça va
se réaliser ça reste très improbable
peut-être qu'on va se rendre compte
qu'après le sommet de versailles les
dirigeants européens sont très très
prudent et cherche à calmer ses opinions
publiques pour leur dire écoutez ouh la
la faites attention nous faisons
attention il faut pas du tout que le
conflit s'exporte opinion publique et
versatile et on ne sait pas si cette
cette solidarité qui s'exprime en verre
une colonne et 7 sont concernées
seraient que les français leur insu les
enquêtes d'opinion c'est 80 % donc c'est
énorme et ça dure combien de temps
est-ce que est ce que dans un an
la réponse alors on m'y a consacré un
débat hier donc jeu
je voulais pas qu'on y repasse trop de
temps mais quand même la question de la
défense européenne elle est aussi au
coeur de ceux de ce sommet de versailles
vincent couronne je me tourne vers vous
parce que aujourd'hui
bon ça n'existe pas de fait on peut
parler de chimères ou d'embryons enfin
bon il n'y a pas de défense européenne
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de ce
sommet selon vous sur ce point précis le
l'élément le plus important je vais vous
laisser le détail et c'est que
l'allemagne a changé de pied évidemment
oui alors précisément de ce conseil
européen sur la question la défense a
priori on ne peut pas attendre grand
chose il y a déjà un projet un avant
projet de conclusions qui a été publiée
qui a fuité il ya quelques heures est ce
que montre cet avant projet de
conclusions du conseil européen c'est
que les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
vont s'engager seulement sur quelques
petites choses mais la mesure phare ça
serait mieux financer
les armements les armées etc mais pas de
modifier d'un point de vue
institutionnel la manière qu'on a de
gérer nos armes et en europe pour aller
vers une intégration plus poussée
militaire européenne donc il n'y a pas
énormément à attendre de ce conseil
européen strictement sur ce plan là même
si un même si on n'est pas à l'abri que
que eh bien il ya un emballement surtout
après le bol des bombardements de
l'hôpital à marioupol et ce terrain qui
est une émotion qui fasse qu'il va y
aller plus loin aujourd'hui ou demain
après il faut il faut dire aussi que
l'europe de la défense en tout cas la
défense européenne jusque là elle et
elle est quasi inexistante il ya des
groupements tactiques qui ont été créés
il ya des années mais qui n'ont jamais
servi
la force takouba qui était venu en
soutien aux français de barques anomalie
c'est une toute petite force 2001 2000
hommes à peine et donc au final il faut
pas quand même se dire que demain on va
se réveiller avec une armée européenne
s'est totalement illusoire c'est quelque
chose qui prendrait si on voulait aller
vers la plusieurs probablement dizaine
d'années
sur la partie énergie revient que les
mesures les plus importantes seront sans
doute un on va rester prudent et on
l'est depuis début de ce débat annoncé
avec une question et on va terminer il
nous reste trois quatre minutes là
dessus sur les les conséquences pour
notre économie et là je vous propose
d'entendre marine le pen sur cette
question
marine le pen l'après la candidate du
rassemblement utiliser ce levier c'est
sanctionner très gravement très
lourdement les français les entreprises
françaises l'économie française qui
pourrait mettre des années à se relever
les conséquences pourraient être bien
pires que les conséquences de la
pandémie donc il faut à tout prix
choisir des sanctions qui ne soient pas
des sanctions ont été contre le pouvoir
d'achat des français et contre notre
activité économique et donc l'emploi en
france marine le pen qui s'opposent à un
embargo sur le gaz et le pétrole russe
marine le pen qui je le rappelle a mis
au pilon plus d'un million d'exemplaires
d'un tract de campagne parce qu'une
photo où elle posait avec la dîmière
poutine faisait tâche forcément bref sur
le fond olivier dorgan est-ce qu'il ya
effectivement un risque il ya eu des
contres sanctions annoncées par la
russie aujourd'hui avec un certain de
deux produits qui vont être interdits
sur le sol russe c'est pas nouveau il y
en avait déjà
en 2014 2015 donc quel impact pour
l'économie française voilà elle est trop
vaste elle elle est très vaste peut-être
pour rebondir sur sur la pollution
marine le pen la question de l'énergie
je pense qu'il faut déjà distingué le
gaz et le pétrole s'est pas tout à fait
la même chose on a déjà parlé de la
dépendance et sur le pétrole on est
aussi très dépendant des décisions de
l'opep des canaux comme le canal j'ai
rien on n'a pas du tout parlé dans ce
débat également de la question iranienne
et vénézuélienne qui est revenue au
coeur du débat les américains ont envoyé
des délégations diplomatiques au
venezuela dans une optique de voir dans
quelle mesure ils pouvaient lever les
sanctions change pays l'iran est sur le
point de revenir éventuellement dans
l'accord de vienne les deux plus grandes
démocraties de la planète non plus pour
contrer justement cette cette
spéculation sur le baril de brent
tout dépendra de la manière dont se
réapprovisionnent et après il ya une
question peut-être c'est à cela qu'elle
fait effectivement union c'est la
question de la fiscalité de l'énergie
qui a une fille zine on est doctrine
pour le coup du gouvernement qui est qui
est assez claire qui est défendu par
bruno le maire on ne touche pas à la
fiscalité on va éventuellement apporter
un soutien financier ou pas aux ménages
les plus précaires mais on ne touche pas
à la fiscalité peut-être que dans une
hypothèse noir de dans l'embargo sur le
pétrole et d'une réaction de l'opep ou
qui ne serait pas celle attendue ou de
renom soutien de l'algérie de l'iran ou
du venezuela avec une augmentation
significative des prix du baril
peut-être qu'en ce moment serait obligé
de revenir sur cette doctrine mais avec
pour le coup des conséquences très forte
sur les recettes fiscales françaises
luxe est une des principales sources de
du fonctionnement de notre de notre état
irina dmitri chine on va terminer avec
vous on l'a dit il ya peu de chances
qu'ils aient un embargo total mais
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire vaciller
parce que l'économie russe elle souffre
en ce moment donc est ce qu'une telle
mesure pourrait faire vaciller le
pouvoir de vladimir poutine qu'est-ce
qui peut le faire voici
bien malin celui qui pourra le dire je
pense que les sanctions déjà agir dans
la durée donc donc donc ce temps ils
jouent contre la russie est peut-être en
faveur de
2 le cren à condition qu'elle puisse
avoir suffisamment de forces pour
résister à condition que ni qu'il n'ya
pas d'épisode comme nous avons vu hier
donc donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
sanctions et les pressions doivent
d'abord essayé d'arrêter ses pilonnages
contre contre les populations civiles et
de sur les données à l'ukraine les tous
les moyens pour se défendre merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat sylvain kahn rappel le titre
de votre livre histoire de la
construction de l'europe depuis 1945 aux
presses universitaires de france
merci à toutes les équipes de public
sénat
de nous accompagner parce que ses
émissions c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé avec l'actualité c'est encore
plus compliqué évidemment merci à toutes
et à tous deux